alors
alors là on aurait dit barracuda quand
vous avez pris le papier hussein dans
l'avion story ce qu'il mangeait tout
temps les papiers mais pas de ça je vous
en foutez de ce qu'il a pas d'autres
amis autour de la table voulait de sympa
avec moi elle est en bas juste après
dans sa collection m'a dit votre bon
c'est une ce soir présenté l'émission
sur cet album ce ton poste avec le
retour de marlène schiappa secrétaire
d'état ou vers la france est elle
raciste mais après ça c'est pour ça que
depuis quelques temps vous devez de plus
en plus élégant ça se voit et ça se voit
dans votre tenue ça soit dans votre
langage
donc j'ai voulu s'essayer dans votre
langage je me suis intéressé à votre
langage pour la phrase la plus élégante
de cyril hanouna
les nommés sont
cyril hanouna qui n'hésite pas à
s'épancher sur son intimité dans
l'émission qu'est ce qu'il a fait pour
nous inquiéter soleil vous savez quand
j'ai vu les images qui étaient aux
toilettes
j'aime faire des choses j'ai eu la
chiasse si la nuit qui n'hésite pas à
employer des expressions qui met en
valeur la langue française tf a déjà
décidé de remplacer
ferry paraisse mittenaere ressort de
quel côté vous êtes alors franchement
mais cette querelle jours battant le cul
[Rires]
cyril hanouna qui n'hésite pas à
dévoiler ce que je suis la direction de
son entreprise pendant l'émission ça tu
pouvais le bac comme le dit la
productrice parce qu'elle n'a pas écouté
mes explications
1.2.3 moins de bouffer le studio neil
stein
je ne donne que les japonais de l'année
les matches à venir merci j'aimerais pas
voilà tout ce que je dirai voir les
images alors on va connaître dans
quelques instants le tabac de la semaine
celui qui a le plus malmené ses
collègues mais en attendant vous allez
devoir désigner celui qu'elle réalisait
le plus beau tacle ces derniers jours y
en a beaucoup
ah voici les nommés pour le meilleur
tacle gilles verdez pour son grand
respect pour jean michel maire l'ancien
reporter de guerre
quelques journalistes jean l'espace
privé de jacques chirac l'attendait nu
au milieu du volley attendait qui
viennent absolument c'est dans un autre
livre très sérieux le fait que l'accusé
quoi mais c'est quoi la demeure c'était
quoi la coaccusée moi ça à lille
d'arnaud ardoin sérieux sur jacques
chirac que j'ai lu et l'anecdote non non
non c'est symbolique sérieux contre à
moi avoue jean-michel
la régie de tpm paix qui se venge de
cyril hanouna et mention spéciale aux
invités qui se demandent où ils sont
tombés voulu me mettre plus de musique 1
quand on revient mettez-moi petit truc
quand même pu témoigner trick
et cyril hanouna qui manifestement
reconnaît valérie bénaïm encore mieux
que patoche saffroy ici sur un panneau
aa je transforme en bâtonnets ça fait
quinze fois qu'on leur dit d'arrêter la
clim mais non ils se font plaisir et de
le faire un pêcheur comme à la chaux
[Applaudissements]
la biogue la loge et il en faut ça fait
genre de la peau de l'info c'est la
dernière ok très bien alors magnifique
merci la chaleur en paraît tout votre
corps à vos beynat c'est bientôt la
saint valentin
bien sûr ouais et j'ai remarqué vous
étiez déjà en mots d'amour vous tuera
conçu si vous êtes en mots d'amour parce
qu'on photo ap 3 2 comme conneries vous
dévoilez vos sentiments prouve aux gens
que vous aimez
ah ouais ouais si vous aimez le plus
c'est michel cymes vous en parler
tellement souvent que je vais c'est de
faire le tabac sait pas encore quand la
pensée lewarde de la meilleure
déclaration d'amour à michel cymes vous
allez voir cyril hanouna qui est
manifestement un grand fan de michel
cymes le comédien france 3 hier
rediffusé meurtre en pays d'auch lire on
l'a très bien marché d'ailleurs voilà 4
2 millions de téléspectateurs et
téléfilms avait michel cymes et jouer le
rôle d'un médecin
elle va regarder une petite compil du
style siemens en tant qu'acteur vous me
direz si vous le trouvez vous pas à
regarder
franchement regardez
cyril hanouna qui est admirative de
michel cymes l'homme aux multiples
casquettes
michel cymes on n'en peut plus
facilement il veut manger à tous les
restes l'animateur préféré des français
lauda il est médecin frère va consulter
des bras dans un hôpital bavarois
stéthoscope et va faire le dos rond
arrête de vouloir prendre l'oseille de
partout mon frérot sans déconner cyril
hanouna qui aiment tellement michel
cymes qui lui donne un conseil médical
francs via des émissions qu'on dise ça
marche pas ça marche pas constellé nous
ont pas appelé parce qu'on a dit que la
course des héros n'avait pas marché la
course des champions
voilà donc lui déconvenue un truc sur
lui il appelle tout le monde parce qu'il
appelle tout bas je vous le dis il
appelle tout le monde
il dit oui cyril hanouna présage venir
mais michel on ne tint vite pas voilà
écouterait chez toi continue à prendre
ton stéthoscope aimer le tour
[Applaudissements]
on y revient toujours pas fermé votants
c'est pas possible il nous ils ont cassé
leur meilleur match c'est normal c'est
dommage avec chaque jeudi je vous
demande de choisir la meilleure blague
de la dernière édition de la grosse
rigolade
ah ouais alors je sais que cette semaine
aussi oui une toile à la on regarder çà
et là de la chance il n'est pas
chronique d'ambition veille du patinage
sur ton crâne y aurait moins de
problèmes c'est vrai beaucoup moins
troubles ses envies de mon crâne
je n'exclus donc des blagues qui sont
diffusées à blanc de l'interroger choix
et rob blake diffusable vous verrez
alors pour la blague la grosse rigolade
et nommer son
mohamed benyamna plus connu sous le nom
de bouder menace passe dans un village
ce village esoain café a compris le truc
raison une équipe de l1 de football
je voulais fowler match dans dans le
terrain mais ils se changent comme non
pas de vestiaires ils changent dans le
café alors ils sont changées ce jour là
ils recevaient saint saint brieuc
l'équipe de n1 de saint brieuc ils se
changent dans les toilettes du café
commencent à sortir un par un pour les
jouer au foot
elle a un mec qui était bourré regarde
un homme donne en croire ses principes
[Rires]
sébastien coué en béton ans invite tous
les jours ni même mais les problèmes
conjugaux à son médecin j'ai un problème
j'ai bien lu d'écouté alors je suis très
embêté parce que je suis pas sexologue
tchèque généraliste mais moi je sais
d'où je sais pas par les fantasmes ne
pas parler de cul ben déjà exposé unis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et jean marie bigard c'est le mec qui
téléphonent au commissariat et 10 pour
ma femme qui avait disparu
vous pouvez arrêter recherche et le fric
et 10e allait rentrer et dit non j'ai
réfléchi
[Rires]
et brian 12e l'e3 il faut oui qui est
enviable la radio aussi écoutez le sur
nrj il est très très bon bigard voilà
qui sera là avec moi demain et mohamed
ben hammam n'a plus connu sous le nom de
bouder il extrait ma passion ou alors on
voulait l'exclusivité maintenant bon
pour demain vous allez voir chez une
blague de philippe lellouche en page
c'est la dernière de cette session après
il y aura pas de grosse rigolade pendant
un petit moment
voilà donc demain c'est à dire je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
ouais c'est relou l'inquiétait pas ça
arrive ça revient très vite c'est
philippe lellouche qui revenue et
excellent film
on a choisi une blague de vaslui choisi
j'ai une histoire juive
vas-y c'est une grand mère qui est
tranquille qui à deauville et elle
tricote sur la plage et là il ya une
lame de fond qui arrive qui prend son
petit fils et qu'il emmène au large
la grand mère elle regarde très
calmement elle se met à genoux en fait
mon dieu c'est pas normal je fais yom
kippour depuis 75 ans j'ai tout fait
shabbat à la maison on mange casher et à
moi tu me prends mon petit fils et à ce
moment-là lame de fond ramène le gosse
qui se remet à jouer sur la plage elle
regarde elle se remet genou elle fait
mon dieu je voudrais pas abuser mais il
avait une casquette 9
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très très grosse grosse rigolade demain
dès 20h45 sur ce but juste après notre
benji qui cartonne web os et donc pour
terminer c'est le grand moment que le
monde entier attend qui sera le 28e
tabac de l'histoire de tpe pme de saint
cyrille sur 27 trophée du tarbes as
coupé me rappeler combien vous avez
gagné données gagné 27 mai 27 je vous le
dis c'est très difficile cette semaine
là maïs trop de n'oubliez pas les
paroles est tombé j'ai peur pour vous je
sais j'ai très peur aussi j'ai peur pour
moi et vous le saurez dans un instant à
tout de suite multiboot leuthard ba ba
de la semaine parce que chaque semaine
marois et nasa il décerne le prix de
celui qui a été le coin du champ le plus
le blanc le bleu clair celui qui tacle
le plus c'est ses collègues et camarades
cyril gagné 27 fois sur 27 pour
l'instant j'ai un peu peur que
malheureusement il n'y pas une 28e fois
eh bien écoutez le 28e tard baba ne
touche pas à mon poste et
avant 2006 est ce que tu as l'épreuve
âgées l'épreuve j'ai une minute 15 de
preuves ben vas-y ces partis avaient les
cheveux sont magnifiques j'étais tout
bon ah ouais bah quoi sur les axes où
les sexes vous vous trompez à la cua
vous est ressorti avec vercingétorix
mais je rappelle c'était un test de
culture générale e maxime nous a le
droit de dire je passe alors est ce qu
il est vrai que l'action de manger fait
maigrir non et de machettes
non moi on m'a dit que le fait de manger
ça faisait actionné le deuxième cerveau
c'est bien là le mcdonald's fait mal
on observait que quand les couples après
l'acte sexuel c'est pas à café
l'addition way se mettent en petite
cuillère l'un contre l'autre pendant un
quart d'heure en cuillère quoi vous
mettez en vieille ville où tout j'aime
ton prénom que j'aime tes mots j'aime
ton âme
j'aime ton corps j'aime tes regards
alors il ya tout qui dit moi j'aime
quand tu fermes ta gueule
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]